Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
I hope it's all good.
And if you don't
like the question,
I apologize for asking.
The Supreme Court today rejected
the latest Republican challeng
to Obamacare in a 7-2 decision
So, now, Mitch McConnell wants
to add six more justices.
Following yesterday's summit
with Russian president
Vladimir Putin,
President Biden said,
"I did what I came to do."
He made the statement
immediately after filling
his pockets with Kinder bars
When asked yesterday
by a reporter
whether relations
between Russia and the U.S
might enter a new era,
Russian President
Vladimir Putin said,
"There is no happiness in life."
Sounds rough,
but that's just what you get
when you translate the
kitten poster into Russian
According to a new report,
Rudy Guiliani is not invited
to his family's
12-person group chat.
Aw, man.
How's he supposed
to meet any ladies?
As a reminder,
he was married to his cousin
[ Laughter ]
This is the key element.
According to a new survey,
just 5% of baby boomers
said that they would
plan a pregnancy
around their baby's
potential astrological sign.
Though, if a Boomer has a baby
it was definitely not planned.
A teenager in Portugal
recently discovered
a message in a bottle
that was dropped
in the Atlantic Ocean
by a teenager in Rhode Islan
three years ago.
And even though it was a note,
their exchange
was still awkward.
Authorities recently arreste
a Brooklyn man
after he allegedly threw a bag
with $20,000
worth of marijuana
off of a rooftop
during a dispute
and caused people on the groun
to chase after the drugs.
And it was chaos.
People were pushing and yelling,
"Is this indica or sativa?
Because I have something
for sleeping,
but I need something
for back pain.
Also, do you have any gummies?
Because smoking
hurts my throat."
Singer Rihanna's lingerie line
"Savage X Fenty"
recently unveiled a new line
of open-back
crotchless leggings.
So, socks?
I think she's selling socks?
I support you, Ri!
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Rihanna's lingerie line
unveiled a new line of
open-back crotchless legging
that reveal the wearer's butt.
Well, over in men's fashion,
they've added an 18th pocket
to cargo shorts.
And finally, officials
in Washington State
announced yesterday
that scientists found
a dead so-called "murder hornet"
near Seattle,
which can only mean one thing --
vigilante hornets.
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue